los bomberos ganan terreno al fuego en
el popular parque nacional yosemite en
california pero las llamas amenazan un
bosque de más de sus 500 icónica
secuoyas gigantes algunos de estos
árboles tienen más de 2000 años
estoy parado justo en frente de chrysler
giant que es posiblemente uno de los
árboles más famosos de la tierra y
tenemos un sistema de rociadores a su
alrededor estamos tratando de brindarle
primeros auxilios preventivos y
asegurarnos de que el fuego no viene
para acá
los trabajadores del parque hacen todo
lo posible para evitar que el fuego
activo desde el pasado jueves penetren
en el bosque mariposa y es que a pesar
de su gruesa corteza las secuoyas
nativas se han vuelto más vulnerables
debido a las sequías y a los cada vez
más recurrentes incendios forestales
consecuencia de los cambios extremos
exacerbados por el calentamiento global
nuestras condiciones son extremas en el
oeste hemos tenido años de sequía hemos
tenido un invierno muy pobre en las
sierras el manto de nieve no estaba
normal no es nuestros ríos están bajos
nuestros lagos están bajos nuestros
embalses están bajos el incendio en el
parque está controlado a un 25% y ya ha
arrasado con unas mil hectáreas ahora
las altas temperaturas de los últimos
días dificultan las tareas sólo en 2022
los bomberos del estado han declarado
más de 3500 incendios forestales